- Hello welcome to Ed
Talks with Khan Academy.
We are excited to have you here
as we talk to people who are influential
in the education space.
Today, we're talking to Olav Schewe
who has a book coming out
that we're looking forward
to talking to about learning.
Before we get started, we
want to remind you first
that Khan Academy is a non-profit
and we rely on donations
from folks like you to help us
do the work that we're doing.
So if you have the ability to
whatever amount works for you
to help us continue on our mission
we really appreciate that support.
We also, during COVID-19
we had some companies that
have really stepped up
and wanna express our
appreciation for them.
Those include Bank of
America, AT&T, Google.org,
NOVARTIS, Fastly and
general motors, thank you.
Also, if you want to catch up
on some of the video
chats that you have missed
and maybe you're on the go
and wanna catch a podcast
you can catch them on the
homeroom with Sal the podcast
wherever you get your podcasts
and find those and enjoy
in you're in your spare time
or on the elliptical as I do.
And so today, as I said,
we have an author with us
who has today released in the US
"Learn Like a Pro" Science-Based Tools
to Become Better at Anything.
Olav Schewe is joining us today
and we're looking forward
to talking about learning.
Welcome Olav.
- Thank you.
- It is great to have you here.
So first as we get started,
I'd like to just find out
from people how they got to
be interested in learning.
Most of us were students at some points
and struggled at different
points with learning
and how that came in, but
not everyone takes that
and says I'm gonna become
an expert at this thing.
So how did you take that journey?
- So we need to go back
to junior high school
when I was quite average
student in most respects.
And I noticed that around that time,
that's when we started getting grades
on the tests that we were doing.
And I found out that I
was sort of quite average
and other students were doing better
and I struggled to reach the
top of the grading scale.
And so I assumed that in
order to get good results
in school, you have to be very smart.
And I had a worldview
that some people were
born extremely intelligent
and they did well
and the rest didn't stand a
chance to do well in school.
But then I also discovered
that those in class
who got the good grades
they have other study habits than I had,
they had other study methods.
And so I thought what
would happen if I adapted
the way I studied?
So I started reading about how to learn
and that eventually helped me
improve my results in school.
I eventually graduated with
the highest grade point average
in high school.
I was admitted to the
University of Oxford.
And, so I really benefited in my life
from learning about learning.
And once I was done with my education
I wanted to help others
learn how to learn, so.
- That's great, so what is something that
back in those days that you actually tried
and what you found to be helpful for you?
- So back in those days,
typically when I was reading
I thought that the
number of times you read
the more you read something the better.
So if I read through a chapter
three times, for example
that would be great.
And that would be three times as good
as if I only read through it once.
What I discovered, however was that
even after reading it three times
I didn't necessarily remember it so much.
And if I slowed down and stopped
to think about what I was reading,
checking if I had understood
it, I retained much more.
And so that was just one small discovery
and I made tons of these discoveries.
I also tried a lot of things
that didn't work very well.
For example, I listened to audio
books at night during sleep
and thought that might be a
very efficient way to learn
but I woke up very grumpy and tired.
But I did a lot of this
experiment thing back and forth
and eventually found some
really good ways to learn.
- Yeah, I had a friend
who used to read her notes
and then make similarly
play them when she slept.
And she realized it was
actually not the playing
them when she slept
but it was like reading
through and saying the notes
in her own words again, that
was actually helping her learn.
And she didn't need to play
them while she was sleeping
to get the benefit of that.
(Olav mumbles)
Exactly I also had that reading piece
was my experience as well.
Like you feel like if I just
highlight the right things
and then keep read, rereading them
that must get it into my brain
and turns out that's not
how it works so much.
- Well also what many people will do
is that they paraphrase for example.
So they have something written in the book
and then they just copy that
over to their own notes.
And it can take a lot of time
and it takes a lot of effort
but you might transfer something
over onto another paper
but it doesn't transfer
into your long-term memory.
- Yeah absolutely, so before
we get more into that,
let me also ask so I know you did this
language learning experiment
in Buenos Aires Argentina,
tell us a little bit about that.
- Yeah, so I've always been
interested in languages
and foreign cultures, and I've
been wanting to learn Spanish
for quite a long time actually,
but learning a language
is such a massive big task.
And I never really had
the time to focus on it
and really pursue it.
But then I had some time
right before the pandemic
and I thought now I've spent so much time
learning about learning.
So I created a challenge for myself
where I tried to see if I
could become fluent in Spanish
in just one month by
applying the best techniques
for learning that I had come across
and by focusing on it fully
for one month and I did it
and one week ago I released
a documentary about it.
That's on YouTube in
case you wanna see how--
- That's excellent, that is great
that you got to do it right
before the pandemic hit
reality to stay home,
so you're good timing.
- Yeah that was actually excellent timing
it was just like before
everything closed down.
- Excellent that is great.
Well, I as you said I caught it on YouTube
as I was looking kinda doing
some research for this show
and was interested to
see what you had done.
So what prompted you to write this book?
- So this book is a joint project
between myself and Dr. Barbara Oakley
who also written several
other books on learning.
And we connected a few years ago
we both published our first
book about learning in 2014
and in both books did fairly well.
And then a few years ago
we connected, we found,
we sort of found a lot of common ground
and we decided to write the
next book on how to learn
taking into account
everything we have learned
since the last book that
we've wrote about learning.
And we also felt that
people now are so busy
there's so much to do, there's
so many things to learn
that there was a need for a
very concise to the point book
that explains what you should do
but also why, but in
a very concise manner.
So we challenged ourselves
to write a very handy book
and that book was published today.
- Great, great so viewers
there was a reminder
you can put questions in the chat here.
So let's dive into some of
the pieces about learning.
So one of the big pieces about learning
is how do we move things from
kinda that working memory
where it's active and we're
able to manipulate things
into our long-term memory,
where we can access it later
and think about where things are.
What are some good ways
to be able to do that
to get that information
into long-term memory?
- So there are several of course
but what psychology has found
is that one of the most robust
and best techniques is
a retrieval practice.
And it's funny because when we're learning
we often want to place
things into long-term memory
but it turns out the
best way to get things
into long-term memory is to take it out
retrieve it out as many times as possible.
So retrieval practices,
can be really anything
where you try to remember
what you've just read.
It can be closing a book
after you read a chapter
and then trying to recall
what you just read.
It can be writing down
what you've just learned,
it can be studying with flashcards.
For example, you see you're
learning foreign vocabulary
you see the word in English on one side
and then you try to remember
what the foreign language version was
that's on the other side.
And you can also discuss
with others but then
without too much help,
just try to recall from your own memory.
- Yeah, it always strikes me
that when you're trying
to remember something
what you're doing is you're
pulling it out of memory.
So that's what you should practice doing
is pulling things out to
be able to access them
that always (mumbles)
- It's almost as if you
were storing something
into the forest and it
can be easy to forget
where it's stored
but if you make a path
and you walk that path,
back and forth enough times
that vegetation will break down
and then you'll have a very
solid path that makes it
easier for you to access,
whatever you've stored there.
And so it's really about
using what you learned
not just passively absorbing or,
but actually actively using it
and bringing it out of long-term memory.
- That makes sense so how do you,
I know that Dr. Oakley does
a lot of neuroscience work
and there's a lot of in
the book neuroscience basis
for a lot of these things.
What are some things that you
found that kind of explanation
for that you found was really
helpful in understanding
why maybe something works for learning?
Is there an example of where
there's a good biological basis
for the recommendation that you're making?
- Yes I'd say, I mean over
and we put emphasis on that
in the book also showing
why certain techniques work.
And what I find is that
when you understand
a little bit of the neuroscience
it becomes much easier
to use good techniques
because you get a much
richer understanding
of the techniques.
So you can apply them a little bit better
in the right situations, extra.
And so one of the things
that I found very helpful
from neuroscience, which
Barb has been teaching
for a few years is this difference
between the task positive and
the task negative networks
which we call the diffused
and the focused mode of the brain.
And basically what that means is that
the brain has two different modes
of thinking and learning.
It has a mode which is very focused
which is when you're working actively
to solve a problem or to
think about something.
But then it also has a mode which works
when you are relaxing or
when you are not focusing
intently on something which
we call the diffuse mode.
And it's easy to think
that learning happens only
when you're actively focused on something
you're trying really
hard, but it turns out
a lot of learning also
happens when you're relaxing
because your brain
continues to work on it.
So many students will think
that a good quality is to,
don't give up and to persevere
even if youre actually in
those types of situations
what you need is this diffused mode
that works when you are not focusing,
because that can access information
in a whole different way.
It can help you connect ideas,
so sometimes taking a break
can really help you while learning.
And this is something
you've probably noticed
as well that you were struggling
with a problem in the
evening then you go to sleep
and the next morning you have a solution.
It's because this diffuse
mode keeps working
on things in the background
and you can use this
actually more day to day.
If you're really struggling
with something you're learning
take a break or do something
else and then continue later.
Understanding these two modes for example,
has helped me a lot in my own learning.
- Awesome that is great, so is that like,
is that part of the
explanation of why, when I
used to walk my dog,
sometimes it would seem like
I'm not paying attention to anything
but then all of a sudden,
like when I'd come back
I would seem to sit at my computer
and have lots more
thoughts about the thing
that I was working on instead of...
- Exactly, because you might
think that you're relaxing
you're taking a break and you aren't,
in a way you are but your
brain continues to work
with whatever you were
doing before that break.
Another term for this and
psychology is incubation effect
that, sometimes you have a problem
something that needs to
incubate a little bit.
And it's also what happens
if you struggled to recall
the name of a person,
you might see someone in
the stream and it's like,
oh I know that person, but you
just can't recall the name.
And then all of a sudden,
half an hour later
it kind of falls down from the sky.
It's that diffuse mode that's
been working in the background
trying to find the name
within your long-term memory.
- Got it, so that kind
of relates to a question
that's just come in from
Kelvin Chin on Facebook
it's asked how can we balance our hobbies
with our studies?
And thinking about those two
maybe it's relating to those two modes
but also thinking about, as we think about
how much time should we be studying
and how much time should we
maybe doing some other things.
- Oh, that's a very good question
and it depends on many things, of course
but what we do know is
that if you are learning
a lot of new information,
a part of your brain
called the hippocampus
can get overwhelmed if
you don't take breaks.
So you might think that it's a good idea
to sit for a very long stretch of time,
but your brain struggles to
process all of this information
and taking a few breaks helps the brain
better stored this information
in long-term memory.
So breaks are important for learning
also from that perspective.
And I think, how much time
you should spend learning
it really depends on your ambitions
and how much you have, how
difficult the material is.
But I've always felt that if you do
if you're a full-time
college student, for example
and you sit then and work
for eight hours a day
at the kind of normal work day,
you should be satisfied with
your effort for that day.
And there's actually research showing also
that students who study
too much actually do worse.
Because if you sit for too long of a time
you also tend to become more ineffective.
And at some point it tips
if you just keep adding
more and more hours
- That makes sense, but again
it comes back to those breaks
and giving your brain a chance
to rest that'll make sense.
So it also relates we're
heading into summer
at least here in this hemisphere.
And I know lots of parents
are thinking about,
how much academic time should
they be spending this summer
with their kids and thinking about,
worried that they didn't
achieve everything they wanted
through the last school year
because of all of the pandemic closures.
But as we think about learning
outside of the classroom
are there particular tips and tricks
when you maybe don't the whole structure
of school around you,
but things you can do
to still keep learning when
it's maybe a less formal space?
- Yes, of course and there's
tons of things you can do.
What I would say though, is
that, and we talked a little bit
about this earlier, that a
lot of learning is hard work
especially when you're enrolled in school
and you have all this curriculum
and you have to go through it
and you only have this amount of time
and the most efficient way to learn it
might be a little bit hard.
And so I would say that,
also during the summer
it is important to take a
break and recharge a bit
and to be ready for the new school year.
And I think it's healthy
and good if the kids,
at the end of the summer miss school
and want to come back
rather than being exhausted
but learning doesn't have to
be boring or hard work either.
There's a lot of learning
that can happen that is fun,
and that is an enjoyable activity.
And so I would say,
especially during summer
try to find things to learn,
to do that the students enjoy.
And there's another added
benefit to this as well
and that is that, especially
if you let a curiosity
be an important driver,
so you choose yourself
what you want to learn,
you follow your curiosity.
If you do that, you actually
learn more effectively as well
because getting your curiosity satisfied
it leads to dopamine
production in the brain
which strengthens memories
in long-term memory.
So curiosity can be a very
strong driver for learning
and letting curiosity lead
you is definitely recommended.
- I love that, are there
ways that parents can help
kinda nurture their kids' curiosity or,
help urge them to ask those questions
and to be curious about the world.
- I think if you can
expose kids to novel things
novel in environments,
most kids already are
quite curious about things.
So, I mean there's lots of things
that you can do to stimulate that
and also ask good questions.
So that's, instead of just
going through content or,
for example, if you are
discussing the First World War
and the Second World War,
and you can talk about,
you might dive straight into something
and say, okay, now we're gonna cover how
why the Second World War came about.
But if you instead try to lead up
with an interesting question, for example
that the World War most
of Europe was in ruin
and so many people had died
and countries were poor
and so many families
have lost family members.
Why did another major war breakouts?
How could this happen when
you were just barely recovered
from another major war?
So you tried to find an
angle to where you can pose
an interesting question.
And then that curiosity is awakened
it becomes more enjoyable
and the learning is better as well,
because once you've got curiosity,
information sticks better.
- Yeah, that's really, go ahead.
- Adding choice, there
might be certain things
that you cannot change.
So we got to spend more time on on this
and that's just how it got to be
but there's a thousand ways
that you could do that.
So you could, for example say,
we should spend some time on
this, do you wanna do this?
Do you wanna watch this documentary movie?
Do you wanna go to that museum?
And, do you want to us to
read this book together
giving kids some choice
is also a great way
to boost motivation for something?
- So this ties, well I
think some of that might be
some of the answer to this question
but from Facebook Moniques ask,
oftentimes it's a big jump for kids
from elementary to middle school,
and then middle school to high school
where there's lots of rigorous home works
and deadlines that kinda make them lose
some of that interest in learning.
Maybe even some of that curiosity
we've been talking about
how can you work through that
and what would be your advice?
- I mean, this is a real
challenge and research
all around the world
shows that the more years
kids are in school the
less motivated they become.
So, the starting point, isn't a great one,
but of course there are
many things that you can do
and research on motivation
has come a long way too.
For example, if you are
surrounded by other people
who are motivated for something
some of that motivation
can transfer to you
that's called motivation
contagion in psychology.
And so, expressing some
enthusiasm yourself
with your kids, for what you're learning
or teachers should keep this in mind, too.
If they are really excited
about what they're teaching
they can actually increase the motivation
in their students as
well, so that's one thing.
We're already talked about choice--
- I'll just jump in and
say that Sal always says
the best way to communicate
excitement about something
is to actually be excited
yourself about it.
Yeah, totally makes sense.
- And I couldn't agree more
on neuroscience support sets.
So, I mean that's great, we
already talked about choice.
Perhaps you cannot decide,
what we need to do but you can give
students can not decide what to do
but you can give them
choice in how to do it.
And we also know that
mastery is very important
for learning that the students feel that
they actually learn and they progress.
So paying a little bit
of attention to students'
needs and making sure they get the help
to master new things
is also very important,
because if students have too
many bad experiences in a row
they might lose faith in themselves
and their abilities to learn
and then they don't spend any effort.
And then of course they don't learn
and then it's just a vicious circle.
- Right yeah, I talk a lot
about in motivation research
there's this idea of, if you
think that you'll be successful
when you do something
it's a lot more likely
that you'll try to do that thing.
And if you think you're
not gonna be successful
if you think you're gonna fail
you're not gonna be
motivated to do that thing.
So it's expectancy of success which
of course kind of makes sense.
If you just think about it
who wants to do something
you think you're gonna fail at
but if we can help kids feel like
they're gonna be successful
there's something there.
- And there's a neural
underpinning for this as well
because what gives you
this energy to expel effort
to pursue a task is dopamine.
And dopamine is released in your brain
it gives you this just energy to act.
But from an evolutionary perspective
it's not very efficient
for us to be spending times
on things that we will likely
not be able to succeed with.
So to protect our survival
if you are trying to catch
an eagle flying high up
in the sky by throwing rocks,
you'll probably soon see
that you cannot, that's not possible
you cannot throw rocks that high.
And so your brain will want
you to focus on something else
give up on that task and do something else
that is worthwhile.
So it will cut the dopamine supply
and you will lose
interest in pursuing that.
And that's what happens
when in any type of activity
if we feel that if we no longer
believe that we can succeed
that dopamine level is
quickly lowered in the brain
and then we lose the energy for it.
Whereas if we through
either self-motivation
or we have someone around us
that gives us a little bit
of help or believes in us,
if we get instilled that belief
again, that we can do it,
dopamine production goes up
and we get that energy back
and then we actually succeed with it
because we also have the energy to pursue.
- Fascinating, so we have
a question about your book
from Facebook Manasseh Avani says
is "Learn Like a Pro" good
for a fifth grader to read,
if not, what would you
recommend for young people
to learn about how to learn?
- So for very young people I
would recommend my co-authors
other book "Learning How to Learn"
that book is especially
written kids and teens.
It has a very simple and friendly language
and lots of fun metaphors.
It's probably a book many
kids can read themselves,
but definitely a book they can read
together with their parents.
So that would be my best
bet for young learners.
- Great, so it seems to me
that a lot of these things
that we're talking about are
skills to practice the same way
we practice other kinds of skills,
like learning how to ride your bike
or do those kinds of things.
Is learning to learn,
should we be having our kids
practice learning behaviors
in similar ways?
- Yes, we should and I mean,
there's good evidence that
some students are better
at picking up good study techniques
and good study habits on their own.
They're experimenting a little bit,
they're reflecting about how they learn.
And whereas other students might be stuck
with very ineffective ways to study
but that doesn't mean
that they can't improve
because they can also
learn better techniques
but they need a little bit of extra help.
And so learning as a
skill is important as well
and should be honed and
sort of throughout life,
not only during early years,
but learning challenges
and context keeps changing
throughout our lives.
But one of the things that can help you
in any learning situation
is being metacognitive
which is a very fancy word for
thinking about how you are thinking.
And I mean research shows that some people
does this more naturally,
they take a step back
and they, look at how they're learning.
And they're asking
themselves whether they are
working in a smart way
or whether they should change something.
But this is also something
you can practice,
with your kids, if
you're learning together
and you can ask your kids questions
about how they've been learning
that forces them to reflect
for example, how are we gonna learn this?
What do you suggest, why do
you want to learn in that way?
And after you've had
a session, you can ask
how did you think that this went?
Is there something you would have done
differently next time?
So often in education
we're very good at asking
questions about the content
but we should spend a little bit more time
about the process of learning
as well, how we are learning
and reflecting and
thinking about that too.
- That definitely makes sense
and that process of how did it go?
It strikes me there's some
potentially goal setting
that is maybe helpful there
too, about at the beginning
what do you want to learn?
So that at the end, you
can say, did we get there?
And where that is like
that kind of goal setting
and reflection helpful based
on the research you've seen.
- Yeah that's normally part of it.
So in the beginning, you set a goal
and you also try to understand
what the success criteria is
or what sort of what you need to learn.
And then you select some
tools or some strategies
and which techniques you
should use depend completely
on the learning challenge itself.
One technique might be great for something
but not work for something else.
And that's also why
it's important to think
of learning techniques
as a kind of toolkit
and mental toolkit that
you keep developing
so that you have strong tools
but also the knowledge
about when to apply them.
And then typically at the
end, you will look back
and you will see whether
you reach your goal
and whether you selected
the appropriate tool
or whether you would want
to do something different
than other time.
- That makes sense, so
that seems like a good note
to bee us on a mental toolkit
that you developed throughout
your life, I liked it.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
Just brush the surface 30
minutes always goes by so fast
but for people who were
interested, picked up the book
"Learn Like a Pro" out today.
We're actually gonna have
Dr. Oakley on June 15th.
She also has a book aimed
particularly at teachers
that is also interesting
that we're gonna talk to her about.
So stay tuned for that and
we will see you next time.
Thank you for joining us.